okay show of hands who in the room is
working on a product or an app that is
designed to improve people's lives in
some way or another hands are up in the
room if your hand is not up get out just
kidding okay so if that is true if we're
looking to help people right improve
their lives in some way then the key
question that we need to answer is how
do we survive over the long term how do
we increase long term engagement so that
we can better do this over time and
that's what I'm going to be talking
about today but I want to start with a
story something that happened to me
recently on a trip to Montreal that I
think everyone can relate to it speaks
to a problem that everyone in this room
has now what happened the story I want
to tell is about the travel portion that
on a trip to Montreal Montreal is a
wonderful City I highly recommend it but
that's not what I want to talk about I
want to tell you about the trip going
there I happen to check a bag I hate
doing this it's super inefficient but I
did so because it was a longer trip
check my bag take the flight the flights
delayed by the time we land you know
everyone is just we just want our bags
we just want to get out of there and
it's taking forever for the bags to come
out what happens then finally beep beep
beep we hear the sound that we all want
to hear the luggage carousel is starting
awesome
so everyone crowds round I'm sure you
can you are familiar with the scene
everyone crowds round as close as they
possibly can to the luggage carousel now
there's only so much room in front of
that luggage carousel not everyone can
be at the very front so if you're one of
those poor souls in the back you're sort
of crouching and looking behind you know
in between heads seeing trying to see
where your luggage is coming out finally
you see it and you know again your block
so you excuse me sir sorry can I get
through here and you get your luggage
and you can finally get out of there
great now if we don't think about this
scenario for a second we probably all
realize it would be better if we all
stood back maybe a foot a foot and a
half that way there'd be enough room
when your luggage actually comes out
that's the real time you need to become
up there's plenty of space
you can get your luggage you don't
bruise and bump anyone on the way and
the solution works better for everyone
but individually if you think of this
idea or if I think of this idea and you
just want to stay on it say I'm gonna
stand back what's gonna happen you're
just gonna be that one chump in the back
everyone's gonna crowd in front of you
and you're not gonna be able to see your
luggage and you're kind of at the same
place but some of you probably have seen
airports where their luggage carousels
are designed a little bit differently
they have a white line painted raise
your hand if you've seen this somewhere
around the world right there's a white
line painted and what happens then is
everyone stands back a little bit and
the whole system works better and so
this is what I want to talk about today
is how do we create this white line for
ourselves in our space and what space
are we in the attention economy every
single one in this room whether you like
it or not you are battling for people's
attention I would say to the death but
maybe that's a little overdramatic so
you we really all have to be fighting
for people's attention and there's a
limited amount of time in the day
there's a limited amount of attention
that they have and we're all battling
each other for this attention and what
are we doing that what's the main
currency in the attention economy its
notifications that is the tool that
we're using in this fight for people's
attention and why are we turning why are
we relying so heavily on notifications
because we learned very early on a
lovely gentleman named BF Skinner taught
us about the importance of random
reinforcement so we did these
experiments with rats where he set it up
so that the rat would come up and push a
lever and when they did that food would
come out awesome what he learned though
is that if you set up the lever
differently so that food doesn't come
out every time but only some of the time
what happens then to the rat exactly I
see someone going like this that's
exactly what happened so the rat pushes
the lever much more frequently when it's
set up to give food
all of the time but only some of the
time and I'm sorry to say that we
whether we like it or not are much more
like rats than we might want to admit
think of a facebook notification right
you don't know what its gonna be
it could be alike it could be a comment
if it's a comment I gotta go figure out
is it a good comment it's bad comment or
it could just be oh it's that rant you
know your random Uncle Tom that you
never talked to his birthday today
there's this whole range of what this
notification can be and it's the fact of
not knowing it's gonna be a good one is
gonna be a bad one isn't be a neutral
one that is what creates this really
really strong pull of notifications now
we know this the challenge though for us
is that notifications can be very very
problematic in many ways these are
unintended consequences I'm not saying
that anyone is meaningfully doing this
but there are a lot of lot of areas and
errors is the first one as my slide
already tells you so that this is really
well researched so for example an in
terms of errors there's lots of studies
that bring people in and then divide
them into two groups so random
assignment right we'll take literally if
it was this room we would take you half
here you'd be in Group A you have here
you would be in Group B we'd put you in
different rooms but then we would give
you the same task usually it's a
quantitative sort of math test math
assignment that you do and let's pick
Group group a is the lucky group you
guys while you're doing your math
problem we're gonna ping you with
notifications as you're doing it group B
sorry no notifications for you and what
happens in how successfully people do
this math problem who thinks they're
equal awesome everyone's paying
attention who thinks that group a makes
more errors you guys are really smart
group this is true so they're making a
group a makes many more errors actually
and I'm very struck by this depending on
the study it's not like 5% 10% it's
actually
about double the error rate twice as
many errors so I just wanna let that
sink in for a second and especially
think about the fact that you know we
use this term our users we talk about
our users and that's you know what we
say in the industry but I want to pause
on this and say our users are real
people of course our users are our
doctors they're our teachers there are
the engineers who are building our
bridges you know do we want to be
setting up a system where we're
potentially doubling the error rate of
what they're doing probably not right
the second area where notified
notifications can be problematic is with
time cost so specifically like switching
costs so you're doing one thing you get
a notification you look at that you open
the app you kind of get sucked down that
rabbit hole for a little while and you
come back to what you were doing so
Gloria Marc has shown us that it takes
us an average of 23 minutes to refocus
on our original task and that's from one
interruption multiply that out through
the day and we think about you know what
is this total cost on human productivity
what are all the amazing things we could
be doing if we weren't you know
incurring these switching costs and
related to this
there's also measurable stress and
frustration so we can measure this
psychologically and that comes from this
idea of like oh I've got distracted and
now I have to spend this mental energy
emotional energy refocusing on what I'm
doing so what does all of this mean does
this mean that notifications are all bad
probably not I also actually do want to
touch on this the fact that we can see I
eyed nerd it out for a second and told
you all up about the studies because I'm
a behavioral scientist and I do that but
we can also even if I didn't tell you
about the studies you probably already
know this right from looking at the
media the headlines that we see out
there six ways to overcome smartphone
addiction 10 tricks for checking your
phone less I mean these are diamond
doesn't we see these all the time we see
this trend of millennia
you know turning off their social media
entirely or going on month-long social
media breaks we also even see these I'm
kind of you know sass it's kind of funny
and sad at the same time that there are
these things called digital detox
retreats where people literally pay
money to have their phones taken away
from them this is in Silicon Valley is
there is there any shock on that so we
see this in the media we see this in the
app space even right we see more and
more apps try to help people deal with
the fact that there's this sort of
love/hate relationship with their phones
how can I better understand how many
minutes I'm spending on my phone how can
I not let it have such a strong pull on
my time in my productivity I was struck
recently I discovered this app called
snowball this app specifically turns off
like kind of blocks annoying
notifications that's its whole reason
for being in function in life that's
just one I'm sure there will be many
more in this space so what is this
telling us there's again as I was saying
this is kind of hinting at the fact that
there's a problem here right and it's
for us to think about how can we resolve
this I would argue that as designers of
the system we have some moral
responsibility here we could also just
take that argument aside though we could
just say forget about that that's nice
and all that's how it is we don't care
you could take that argument aside
here's the real kicker notifications
over relying on notifications is bad for
developers and that's what I want to
talk about too so this is a study that
looked at the top reasons that people
uninstall apps uninstall apps is pretty
much the worst case scenario for any of
us right that's the last thing that we
want people to be doing this is a study
in which people were given a lot of
reasons that they could they could
answer they could pick more than one so
the totals do add up to more than a
hundred here but what is the top reason
given annoying notifications this is the
last thing that we want to have
happening combine that with a fact when
we think about our model in this
industry
how sustainable is this this is an
industry where we know we have very high
user acquisition costs right we're
spending lots of money on the front end
to bring in new users new years there's
new users and yet what happens is after
the first month we're retaining 36% of
them the second month twenty-five the
third month down to 20% so another way
to look at this is across all industries
this is an average by the way of all
industries within the app space 80% of
all app users are churning within 90
days this is insane and the question is
how is this sustainable for us we're
gonna run out of users people need to we
better repopulate the earth really
really quickly because we're gonna run
out of users to tap in this in this
model right so the bigger question is
what do we do are we on the ship headed
for self-destruction or other things
that we can do I actually want to talk
about three things that we can do
starting with the most obvious stopping
the madness stopping the attention mat
grabbing madness so I think we can
actually all agree that sending this is
a real scenario sending three
notifications within one hour about the
exact same video that wasn't gonna go
anywhere this video was gonna go
anywhere if I was going to watch it
right that second right this is probably
not being a good citizen I think we can
all agree about that now I'm not as I
said I'm not trying to say that all
notifications are bad the question here
is what boundaries what should up what
would that look like if we kind of said
this is how we want to function in this
space this is a better way of thinking
about this what would that look like
that would be things like let's click
forward to the next slide aligning with
our users intentions so another show of
hands how many people in the room have
some kind of subscription membership
something like that that you have been
meaning to cancel or you probably should
cancel but you haven't gotten around to
doing it yet lots of hands going up in
the room what's up with you guys if
you're if you want to do that why aren't
you doing it
we have this a lot right we have this
with health I mean to eat healthier I
mean to exercise more but I don't these
are challenges this is in psychology
this is called the action intention gap
and our opportunity is to say how can we
bring these two together imagine a world
where we can help people achieve what
they're trying to achieve from healthier
eating to working out more to be more
productive or whatever it is again
whatever yours whichever space you're in
and this would mean that if your
headspace I think I believe headspace is
somewhere in the room if your headspace
let's say that someone downloads your
app meditates for the first three days
but on the fourth day they drop off
sending a notification to ping that user
to come back in meditate today is fully
aligned with that user's intentions
right so this would be a good example of
sending a notification another example
this probably sounds like heresy but we
should not be forcing the users to open
the app when we get a notification this
is a health app obviously mango health
it says it's time to take care of you
you have one health reminder oh and so
then you open the app and you discover
that it tells you to drink water which
is very helpful great I should hydrate I
should drink water contrast though with
Argos that tells you immediately
directly drink water right this is a
much more respectful way of engaging
with our users another example a
positive example if your ways you know
that someone takes 280 regularly hey by
the way - a he's not to shut down very
helpful timely information for that
particular user United Airlines you're
walking to one gate hey by the way your
gate change to another one you might
want to be going that way helpful
information clarity money hey you're
overspending for how you usually spend
you might want to taper that down
helpful timely information relevant to
me
the last example I'm going to give you
is from an app called shape up it's in
the health and weight management space
it's an app that I'm working on and
we know from research that stepping on a
scale daily especially when it's done in
the morning is correlated with weight
loss so this is sort of our baseline
fact that we know so my challenge is to
say okay great now that I know this and
I want you know these people want to
lose weight how do I help them do that I
need to get them to step on the scale
how do I do that notification but how do
I do in a way that we're maybe not going
to be dependent on the notification
forever I ask them to think of a habit
that they already have something that's
already happening in the morning right
do you want to do this before you brush
your teeth after you eat breakfast
before you do your morning yoga so
they're they're choosing which habit
that they want to pair it with they you
know so we give them a list of these
things they ask them what time do they
usually do this and so you're giving the
user choice and you're helping them
build positive habits okay so that was
talking about notifications kind of some
quick examples I could talk all day
about this but some quick examples of
some do's and don'ts the second piece
beyond notifications is about aligning
our metrics with our users goals so for
example if you are Trello ultimately
what is your user trying to do they're
trying to complete projects they're
trying to get stuff done right if you
are an online dating app which I believe
there are many in the room then people
are trying to find a relationship that's
what they're trying to do ultimately and
if you are LinkedIn who's over there
then people are trying to find a job
that they love these are them ultimately
there's probably a lot of other things
that they're doing as well but
ultimately if we have to boil it down to
the top thing that that use our users
are trying to achieve these are the
things right they do not care they are
not looking and thinking about number of
logins number of swipes number of
LinkedIn connections we have these are
different metrics okay and so the
question is what can we do to align
better with our users the other part the
challenging here is our over-reliance
on short term metrics so I imagine that
many of you let's say we have a
dashboard in our office this really big
dashboard and really big at the top we
have all of these metrics but the two
that we focus on the most anyone want to
shout them out what are they daily
active users number of sessions people
are completing right these are these are
two that I see time and time again and
if we think about you know this is in
our office every day we come in we focus
on how do I change these two numbers
what's the obvious answer notifications
I can do I can ping with notifications
right now and I will move the needle on
those two things for sure but the
challenge is that when we're sending a
notification two things are actually
happening one you're getting this short
blip right in engagement right now but
you're also getting long term
deterioration but we're not seeing that
we're not looking at that with such an
intense focus that we have on these
short-term measures and I'm not saying
that we shouldn't measure these
short-term things I'm saying that we
should create a better balance we should
focus more on these longer-term measures
customer lifetime value I know that many
of you in the room are working on this
or have you know put together metrics to
do this and kudos to you it is more
challenging part of that part of the
reason we rely so heavily on short-term
measures is because it's way easier to
calculate you just see it right you
build a little report it's their
customer lifetime value is a lot harder
to calculate aligning with our users
ultimate goals is a lot harder to do but
it's the right thing to do okay one more
piece in terms of driving long-term
engagement is about increasing trust
again a lot of research on how to do
this I will just say briefly think about
any relationship that you have in your
life your spouse you know it could be
romantic it doesn't have to be romantic
it could be your friendships work
colleagues think about any of these
relationships now if you only ever in
these relationships
acted in your own best interest how long
do you think these relationships would
last
not very long right if you only ever
acted for yourself now what makes us
think that this would be any different
in our world imagine a world where
you're lift this is a mock up this is
not real imagine a world where you're
lift and you ping drivers hey it might
be a good time for you to stop driving
right now what would we see remember a
dashboard we would actually see that
number go down a little bit as some of
the drivers would sign off the drivers
that we pinged with this notification
active users go down but think about the
long-term effect on that driver instead
of someone who is I'm not suggesting
that lyft does this but if instead of a
model where someone's like always you
know more more minutes drive more and
more more MORE versus hey I care about
you you've driven probably enough right
now and there's not that much demand
anyway and we're in where you are think
about how that person feels and so this
is just one example and you can come up
with your own as well so what is all of
this about what I'm trying to say here
is that it's our opportunity our time to
band together to create our own code of
ethics when it comes to this attention
economy this is gonna be really hard I'm
not saying it's easy at all but this is
the future luckily for us we don't have
to start from scratch people have dealt
with this before let's think of organic
food imagine the time think back if you
can - before when before organic food
labels existed so you're the organic
food farmer and you want to create
better product that is healthier for
people that isn't polluting the
environment with who knows what kind of
chemicals right you want to do this and
so you're making your grapes and you're
very proud of your grapes and they're
awesome and they go on the shelf and
they're competing with those other
grapes that have pesticides on them
and who and what's the difference the
only difference at that point is price
and you're gonna lose that battle
because at that point the consumer has
no understanding no idea well why would
I pay more for that's all I can see is
these grapes cost more and yet with the
label right this became a signifier a
symbol of the fact that this these
grapes this product was made with a
different set of standards with a
different set of norms it's in a
different category and so I think this
is a really nice example for us to think
about you know can we create something
similar to that the second example I
want to give you is also from food but
it's from the UK so the British
government like our government as well
actually realize that hey we have a
problem with our population obesity
numbers are really way too high people
are very unhealthy how do we fix this
and so one of the things they did is
they turned to the food manufacturers
and said guess what we have two choices
here one we will regulate you we will
come up with a statement set of
standards that you're gonna have to
follow this process is going to be very
expensive very laborious and because we
you know are an outside function we
don't and we might not necessarily come
up with the right answers sorry can we
go back
so that was option a right we will
regulate you second option you guys
regulate yourselves what did the British
food manufacturers do they said
absolutely we will do that they banded
together they created a standards for
sugar content and all kinds of details
on how the products were able to be made
fat content etc they lowered all of
these right so across the board and this
was effort for them they were cost
involved any one of them couldn't have
done it individually the whole reason
why this worked is that they did it
together but then everyone won right
because consumers in the end ended up
with products that were a lot less
sugary so this is again our opportunity
to create something for ourselves
there's examples of this these are just
two that I've given
but ultimately it's time for us to
create our own white line to design a
system that works better for everyone
thank you
[Applause]
you